welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 20 and we're going to learn how you
can create a powerful evening routine so
other than the five-second rule there is
one habit that I have adopted in the
last three years that has fundamentally
changed me as a business person and it
has also changed my ability to manage my
emotions so I don't get hijacked I do
not allow my phone in the bedroom I know
the research Deloitte just did a study
based on phone use alone and 33% of
people are reading emails in the middle
of the night I know that if you go to
bed and the phone is right next to you
right so you go to bed because you need
your phone you know somebody might need
you and you sleep you know if this is
right here and it's not closed and the
blue light is on they've done studies
where you have people at a table and the
researcher will put their phone on the
table not even my phone
the researchers phone and the brain
lights up like crazy just with the
presence of a phone the research around
the phone and sleep is so stunning that
if you were to adopt one radical thing
today other than the five-second rule
try putting your phone outside your
bedroom turn off the little visit so you
don't hear it tell people who need to
reach you to call you my kids I have a
kid in college a kid who's you know high
school kid in middle school if there's
an emergency call me there is nothing
happening on your phone at two o'clock
in the morning that's important but if
you
yourself to become a tool of this this
is supposed to be your tool for selling
your tool for communicating and we're
all becoming the tool here's the other
thing common sense why's that I want you
to understand you wake up the alarm goes
off what do you do what so you're not
even vertical and you're reading emails
and what is in these emails other
people's crap but you don't have
boundaries with this puppy it's gonna
happen and so when I put this thing
outside the bedroom and I wake up I walk
over to where the phone is that you
plugged into my bathroom I turn it off I
don't look at again I gave myself five
minutes five minutes before I tuned into
the world to actually tune in up here to
say what's the one thing I'm gonna get
done today that really matters to me if
you're the kind of person that feels
like you don't have control over your
day that your day gets hijacked that you
can't get to the priorities that you're
always behind the ball
this one planning thing will change your
life no phone in the bedroom turn it off
when the alarm goes off five minutes
five lousy minutes five thousand minutes
before you tune in to the rest of the
world and if you've got the kind of job
where you've got to check it get up ten
minutes earlier you have control over
this stuff and it is so important that
you take it seriously now because you're
living at the slowest moment of your
entire life in that hour to 90 minutes
prior to sleep dim the lights in your
house don't look at any screens anymore
that means no TV and no handhelds you're
not twittering and facebooking and doing
all the other things on your phone and I
really mean no texting either just stop
in that last hour that means if you want
to read a book go ahead read it read a
book yeah don't read liked magazines
with dozens and dozens of pictures to
start dropping dopamine in the back of
your brain stem just read one thing read
one article or one book or journal and
plan your day with no noise no TV I mean
I know you got you might have the kids
and they might be loud everything else
but then turn
evie out yourself and you like but
Brendan I got a fall to see the TV no
you don't you just taught yourself to
trust me thousands and thousands of
years of human history past with no
television they slept just fine
I'm sure if you ever gone camping or
been in the great outdoors you're like
wow I sleep amazing it's because you're
not watching television I hope right now
people there in the campgrounds Travis
punching their iPads you know it's like
you got to turn it off
dim the lights no screens no sounds the
students just chill the last hour and
allow you to kind of glide yourself into
bed calm cool you'll sleep like a champ
I went for ten years with an average of
five to six hours of sleep I felt like
it was genetic and I felt like I had a
ton of energy until something happened
and that thing that happened was I was
totally crushed about two years ago I'd
been burning into both ends working 20
hours a day and not getting any sleep I
went to Hawaii and I said you know I'm
just gonna like I'm gonna have zero
schedule on vacation
I slept 14 hours a day for like six days
straight and I felt completely different
than I had for the previous like six
eight weeks that I've been burning at
both ends now starting about a year ago
I showed it tracking my sleep and I aim
to stay in bed for eight hours a day I
can tell you that I am a definitively
way smarter way nicer more in touch with
my creative side way more in touch with
my intellect and I'm just a better human
when I have more sleep rich why do you
sleep in a tent for those that don't
know for the last two years I've been
sleeping outside in this thing a lot of
people have been asking me why do you do
that and it basically boils down to
three fundamental reasons the first is I
just sleep better in a tent outside the
second reason is that it really has
helped me connect with nature and the
outdoors and I think our primal
disposition and the third reason I've
been doing it
is because fundamentally it's a stoic
practice a couple years ago I started
struggling with trying to get a deep
sleep unless I was training SuperDuper
hard I just found it difficult to get
the restfulness that my body and my mind
need and at the time our bedroom that I
share with my wife Julie was either too
cold for her or too hot for me then I
had an experience where we as a family
all slept on our roof one night we have
flat roof and we did it just for fun
with the kids and I had the most restful
peaceful night of sleep in recent memory
being outdoors breathing that outdoor
air sleeping under the stars is a very
simple and basic way of reconnecting
with what it means to be fundamentally
human we live in this super fast-paced
culture you got to get your hustle on
you got to like work 24 hours a day and
if you're not being productive in every
moment of your waking existence then
you're wasting time and you're falling
behind and with that comes a deep
prioritization of sleep sleep is for
slackers right and nothing could be
further from the truth I know that I
can't perform a my very best unless I
get eight hours of sleep and it's not
just the amount of time that I sleep
it's the quality of that sleep it's the
caliber of that sleep it is my opinion
that everybody should be doing
everything they can to enhance that
quality of their evening hours and I
found that by sleeping in a tent it's
almost like this hack towards improving
the caliber of my sleep so that I can
show up throughout my day and Excel be
totally focused be totally present have
good energy be in a good mood and all of
that derives from sleep so if you really
take the time to prioritize the quality
and the
of time that you're sleeping every night
you will realize quantum gains in your
productivity in your output throughout
your day before we get started do you
mind if I put my phone to sleep here on
this phone bed here can you tell us
about this for yes so we launched thrive
in December 2016 so just over a year ago
and there was one product that I wanted
to launch at the same time with a
company and that's this phone bed it's
actually a charging station we are all
addicted to a phone what we recommend is
that you put this little phone bed
charging station outside all the
bedrooms in the home and then at night
everybody puts their phones to sleep and
you put them under the blankie you talk
the mean you say good night and the idea
is that why the phone is sleeping and
charging you're sleeping and recharge I
love the idea over 70% of people sleep
with their phones by their bed according
to all the latest science the worst
thing you can do for your sleep is to
sleep with your phone on yes the phone
is the repository of every project every
problem everything we're dealing with
when we're awake therefore it needs to
be separated from us when we're asleep
and recharging so you can wake up fully
recharged and deal with whatever Life
brings us when Jeff basis for example
wrote on thrive and a piece the headline
she chose was yes why am i sleeping
eight hours a night is good for Amazon
shareholders it went crazy viral and had
a big impact on people yes because he
analyzed his decision-making yes and he
said the value of bring to Amazon is the
quality of my decisions
and if I get six hours if I get less
than my optimal eight hours
here's analyzed that his decisions are
five to twenty percent less good so I'll
give you my routine I'll give you my
nightly ritual but what I recommend for
everybody watching is to create your own
ritual I mean it's almost like I give
you a menu and you need to experiment
see what is it that does it for you for
me it's like 30 minutes before I'm going
to go to sleep turning off all my
devices and gently escorting them out of
the bedroom it's Gordon a lot you put
them in the little homes outside the
bedroom turning off the lights you know
the bright lights making it turn I just
have one nightstand light and one life
in the bathroom then having a really
really hot
wonderful bath really one bath yeah
we've epsom salts which are very
relaxing and flickering candles but if
you guys don't like baths have a shower
oh my god what I've never used it yeah
you gotta have a shower yeah and hot is
better than coal oh yeah your your basic
you basically want to slow down your
brain and soothe your muscles you know
everything is like powering you down
mm-hmm I guess when you're going out
hotel late at night I always feel ready
to sleep exactly you feel exactly the
hot tub is there a perfect hot tub you
have a hard time go to a hot dog I don't
have a hard-on so and with a bath and
and then put on um if you if you sleep
naked you sleep naked but if you wear
PJs and nitrous or whatever make sure
that you are clothes for bed I used to
sleep in my gym clothes yeah and then
your brain gets this confusing messages
you know what oh gee how are you pouring
down so even if you are a t-shirt make
sure it's not a t-shirt you wear to the
gym and then in bed I only read physical
books hmm I I don't believe anything on
screams and anybody who is reading the
slipper evolution embedded I will
consider it a personal victory if you
actually fall asleep three twenty to
twenty pages and I fall asleep
whatever ten pages you get drowsy you
let the book drop or you turn of the
light you're asleep so that is
incredibly important for those worth
children you know that that's how you
put your child
you don't just drop your child in read
you read to them you read to you give
them a bath you put them in their PJs
you read to them you kind of transition
you know it's like the good night moon
and you say good night for everything
which is really a demarcation line
between your day with all its stresses
however blessed our lives maybe everyday
stresses challenges difficult things and
incompletions there's nobody who has any
interesting job or is a busy mom who
finishes the day and says I did
absolutely every room noise something
that yeah that was on my list I should
have done never yeah
so you need to somehow tell your brain
and your body we did what we did right
this day and now the day has come to a
close and we need to fully charge cross
a line no need to cross that line be a
bad on the screen thinking about work
and then sleep at the same time couldn't
couldn't call up one I just really I
wish I could sort of convey that feeling
that I absolutely totally believe now to
everybody watching because I promise
that if if you do this every aspect of
your life will improve mm-hmm if you
have any lingering doubt that you're not
going to be as productive just try it
yeah because it's like getting in the
Tesla you're going to get your
destination faster right consuming less
energy how do I start my day on the
positive side I often wake up anxious
and stressed well Craig thank you very
much for sending in your question I
would like to respond by first asking
you a question and my question is what
do you do before you go to sleep at
night see most people before they go to
sleep at night either checking the
on social media watching violent TV show
a horror movie or reading a scary book
all of those things can make you have a
very restless sleep and chance us out
when you wake up in the morning you
could feel very anxious and stressed so
for example if you go to sleep thinking
about work then your subconsciousness is
going to be involved throughout the
night on work-related issues and when
you wake up in the morning Challis how
you can be anxious and quite stressed
about it as well so the best way to wake
up not feeling anxious of stress is to
prepare to go to bed and that's not
something that people do very often here
are a few simple things that you can do
to prepare to go to bed you should stop
working at least half an hour before you
go to sleep so turn off your email don't
go on social media it's just completely
shut off go take a shower
prepare to go to bed and when you get to
bed sit on the edge of your bed keep
your spine straight your head nicely
balanced on top of your neck take a slow
deep breath in and then slowly exhale
again and while you're doing this deep
breathing exercise
focus entirely on your spine and if you
can't feel your spine gently move your
back from left to right a little bit so
you can feel your spine focus on your
spine as you breathe in deeply and as
you exhale slowly as well and then just
lay down on your back and go to sleep
and obviously this is going to take
practice you know work the first day the
second day but if you consistently do
this every night before you go to sleep
you'll start having really good deep
restful sleep and then wake up not
feeling anxious stressed how important
is rest and how much do you get of it
I'm trying hard at the moment to pursue
my dreams but sometimes I feel out of
balance because I lack sleep for example
all right boys and girls I'm telling I'm
just gonna be super arrogant for a
second I built a billion-dollar business
without setting an alarm prioritize
sleep I work a lot in fact I'll take the
Pepsi challenge anybody that wants to go
head to toe with me in terms of what you
get done not just raw number of hours
aimed at a computer or whatever it is
you're supposed to be doing and
performing
liesl optimally I'll just take the Pepsi
challenge on that I always prioritize
sleep I always prioritize my
psychological optimization so for
instance if I'm working around the clock
in fact this happened not too long ago I
was just working so many hours and it
ended up encompassing too many things
that took more energy than they were
giving that I started to feel anxious
isn't in fact I started to feel
claustrophobic that's exactly how I felt
I wanted to crawl out of my own skin I
don't know how to explain it it's just
like ah just driving me nuts and I
realized I need to chill for a minute I
need to meditate I need to take an hour
and go do something that's still moving
me towards my dreams because that's my
thing
but that I really enjoy and so maybe in
those moments I go read a comic because
we're building a comic book publishing
Empire so that's part of what I need to
do anyway but reading the comic is fun I
also need to meditate and just literally
breathe from my diaphragm so get the
sleep do you need
that's super critical you do not need to
set an alarm sleep as much as you need
to and by the way if you're doing things
that are exciting to you you're I know
people some of you are gonna believe me
because I hopefully I've earned the
credibility with you up to this point
and some of you're gonna call total
bullsh you can ask my wife I can set an
internal alarm clock in my mind only if
I'm excited about something or really
stressed out but that's a whole nother
thing which I try hardly to do ever but
when I'm really excited about something
I can set an internal alarm clock this
morning I told myself wake up at 4:15
what time did I wake up boys and girls
not for 14 not for 16 I woke up at 4:15
because that was the time that I told
myself to wake up I can usually get
within 5 minutes of what time I tell
myself to wake up it doesn't always work
and if I'm tired I don't give myself
that edict I tell myself to sleep as
much as I need but when I'm really
excited about something there's
something I want to get up and work on
and I'm afraid there just won't be
enough time and it's a reasonable amount
of sleep I'll say anything north of 5
hours I can usually get myself to just
wake up so get the sleep prioritize
cognitive optimization because then
you're efficient in a fish and
see is the name of the game so sleep
sleep sleep I am NOT a guy proposing the
you know set your alarm get up at 4:00
a.m. no matter what it's not me go to
bed early get your sleep meditate
getting a good peaceful calm creative
state so that you can really crush it
I've had the best coach over the last 7
years that I've known him and that's
Craig Valentine what do you thinks the
biggest lesson he learned from him in
the last seven eight years the biggest
lesson was to sleep at the same time
wake up the same time seven days a week
no matter what really his sleep is so
valuable it's so important so I rated I
used to think that I here's what I was
I'm a fighter jet I would literally walk
around the house honey I'm a fighter jet
fighter jet and you know doesn't even
come down to get refueled they're up
there getting refilled right we've all
seen the YouTube videos yeah well the
fighter jet if they leave those
afterburners on too long they just fall
out of the sky which I know one had told
me right until I fell out of the sky I
was having essential tremors and anxiety
attacks and not realizing it and as I
got better at sleep those just went away
cuz the one discipline leads to another
and to another how you do anything is
how you know everything all right and so
that that one thing that he taught me or
I learned through him and we'd be in
Vegas we'd run a mastermind together
because now we run a mastermind together
and at eight o'clock
he's gone buddy were you going sleep
yeah I'm gonna by nine or whatever
better yeah yeah exactly he powers off
thirty minutes all his electronics
before so now I do the same thing I
power off I don't go to bed and then do
this yeah I powered off thirty minutes
before and my mind stops racing and the
left and right side start reconciling of
the information I took in throughout the
day versus the information I keep
consuming taking yeah right until I fall
asleep and then Lord knows what happens
in my brain whatever I write what time
you go to bed and wake up 10:30 10:30
I'm in bed wake up at 5:30 Wow and and
that's it's about no matter what even if
you're in Vegas or I'm traveling around
the world or whatever you know I'll
adjust to that timezone real quickly and
10:30 I'm in bed 5:30 a.m. I wake up and
I go right through my rituals so sleep
my opinions on sleep my opinions and
sleep depend on
how many sessions of sleep you get per
day so most people in this room will be
familiar with what's called monophasic
sleep that's just go to bed wake up you
get one session of sleep if if you're
doing that or speaking from a personal
basis if I'm doing that I like to get 9
to 10 hours of sleep I sleep a lot if on
the other hand you're doing what's
called polyphasic sleep where you break
it up into multiple segments per day and
that can be taken to an extreme and
something called uberman which is I
believe two and a half hours of total
sleep per day which is comprised of
20-minute naps not terribly social as
you can imagine that can be sustained
and there's a lot of debate about this
there are long articles online about why
it's impossible I can't divulge it yet
but I can say right now I'm using some
along with a few other groups some
pretty sophisticated Emin straight that
it is possible
we're tracking people using EGS while
they sleep on uber men so it can be done
should you do it that's a separate
question for most people it's going to
be completely untenable and
unsustainable but there are people like
Matt Mullenweg
usually called the lead developer or one
of the lead developers of WordPress and
while he was working on WordPress he had
his most productive year of coding
probably produced I'm just speculating
here but 60% of the wordpress code in
one year and he was following over man
to most people if you feel like you have
to sleep 2 hours a day to get more done
I would say let's let's look at the time
management first before where you start
cutting you back to 2 hours but those
would be my feelings if you want to be
an effective entrepreneur you need to be
able to have good quality sleep this is
the most important aspect of making sure
that you are running on all cylinders
the quality of your sleep matters just
as much if not more than how long you
sleep and for me as an entrepreneur with
so much on my mind all the time you know
I can't have a mattress that causes me
to toss and turn the more rest I had the
quality of sleep know tossing and
turning the comfort you know it allows
me to to make better decisions have
better
the next day just truly be the most
efficient Garrard that I could possibly
be the more time we spend in bed awake
not sleeping the more time it drives
home the message to our brain into our
body that the bed is the place for
tossing and turning not the place for
sleeping if you if all the time you
spend in bed if most of that time is
spent sleeping you know you train
yourself you program yourself that
that's what the bed is for but on the
other hand if you're spending a lot of
time awake what you end up doing is the
opposite you end up programming yourself
to be awake which is why a lot of times
people can feel really really tired then
they get into bed and their mind starts
going and they don't quite know why I've
been there okay but how if you just
can't sleep does time really matter so
this is a really important question you
know time during the night can be a
slippery thing sometimes it feels like
an hours gone by but it's only been five
minutes but on the other hand sometimes
it feels like only a few minutes have
gone by but it might have been a half an
hour well the problem is the more time
you spend in bed awake not sleeping the
more like they're going to develop some
sort of insomnia so what you need to do
is once you hit around 20-30 minutes
maybe a little more depending on who you
are you've gotten to the point where
that sleep is not happening it's best to
just get out of bed do something else
for a little bit just try to get in a
little while okay so if 30 minutes have
passed get up and do something but what
what kind of activity would you be doing
in the middle of the night exactly so
you want something that's not too
exciting because you want to be able to
put it down in 30 minutes or 45 minutes
or however long you want to give
yourself before you try again so if you
get too engrossed in it so if you're
someone who gets engrossed in a book
that might not be the best idea but if
you're someone for whom the books
relaxes you it's a great idea
also you might want to avoid doing work
because sometimes when people pick up
the computer and start working in the
middle of the night a lot of time can go
by and and you might end up waking
yourself up a little more and it might
be hard to get back to sleep
also don't do anything that involves
turning and turning on the bright lights
and so if you're using a computer or
something make sure the lights are
pretty dim so it doesn't wake you up too
much yeah that's a good point especially
with all the social media we have and
all the gadgets but now that sounds like
we're kind of giving up on the idea of
getting any rest
because we're getting up is that the
case no you're not saying you're not
giving up you're not see what you're
saying is you're being realistic the
sleep isn't happening right now and the
more you chase after it the further away
it's gonna get what you need to do is is
let that anxiety go let that stress go
just accept the fact okay sleep is not
gonna happen right now
but if you're gonna sleep well later you
need to give you need to give it a give
it a break and try again later if
anything you'll end up sleeping more in
the long run the short run may be a
little less but you'll end up sleeping
more in the long run because you're
gonna be programming your bed your brain
that the bed is for sleep and not for
wake the last thing we have to talk
about is improving your sleep
environment and that involves your bed
itself the amount of light in your room
the sounds the odors the temperature a
lot of different factors so we're gonna
briefly go through a few of them here
and while we do that for each one ask
yourself if you could be making any
improvements so first up let's talk
about your pillow couple of things about
pillows number one you want to replace
yours every couple of years both because
it breaks down over time and gets less
supportive but also because every night
you're sleeping on it you're kind of
injecting that pillow with lots of dirt
and germs and body odor and stuff that
makes it gross which can make it harder
to fall asleep secondly and this was
news to me until just recently there are
different kinds of pillows for different
kinds of sleepers for example I am a
side sleeper and for years I was just
using like the most non supportive awful
pillows until I learned that a side
sleeper probably is gonna need a firmer
pillow that has these gussets on the
side of it instead of just the two
pieces of fabric that are stapled
directly together and after sleeping on
this thing for about a week now I can
tell you it is a lot better than the
stuff I was using before when it comes
to the temperature in your room cooler
is better and according to the National
Sleep Foundation the optimal temperature
range for sleeping is somewhere between
60 degrees Fahrenheit and 67 degrees
Fahrenheit the amount of light in your
room or should I say lack of light plays
a big role as well because pitch
darkness actually plays a big role in
melatonin secretion so if you have a lot
of ambient light coming into your room
from like a streetlight outside your
apartment you can pick up a blackout
curtain which will basically eliminate
that light altogether I've actually got
one right there that I use for filming
also if you happen to fall asleep with
the TV on you should probably try to
break that habit
because well blue light now if you're
one of those people who thinks that the
TV is soothing and they just can't fall
asleep without it there are some sound
based alternatives and actually silence
really isn't the optimal solution for
all people because silence is so often
inconsistent there's a bump at night or
there's a voice in the other room or
there's somebody's snoring in the same
room as you
so having some sound that can block out
those inconsistencies can really help
you fall asleep one option you can check
out is ambient noise generators which
can generate both white noise which is
basically just consistent noise that
sounds a little bit like an air
conditioner and ambient noises like rain
and thunder and for me my favorite one
is noise lee because you can add as many
as you want you can change the volume of
each one and basically create the
perfect mix for you there's also a lots
of music out there that's good for
falling asleep - I've made a playlist of
my own and found several unspotted I and
I'll link to those down below but my
favorite way to fall asleep is with
audiobooks for me at least there is
nothing better to fall asleep to than
spoken word and in fact ever since I
discovered audiobooks back when I was
probably 12 or 13 all the way up until I
graduated high school and got a roommate
in college I would fall asleep every
single night to either Ender's Game by
Orson Scott Card or The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy by Douglas Adams and
as a result I have huge swathes of both
of those books basically memorized how
to increase the quality of sleep
don't try to increase the quality of
sleep the ideal way to live is there is
no sleep in my life but that's not
possible right now still body has some
inertia so it sleeps minimum rest at the
time it is at ease if you keep this at
ease then sleep does not occur to the
body unless it comes to a certain point
of exhaustion so body is never ever
asking for sleep but it is definitely
asking for rest if you do not know how
to sit here in a restful manner it will
try to rest
like this if you can sit here totally at
ease it'll sit here for hours without
falling asleep otherwise this is the
only way it knows how to rest so do not
try to increase the quality of sleep
there's no such thing just learn to keep
your body restful and at ease
consciously if you sit here now one
simple thing you can do is you sit down
you come and sit down here just move
your attention from the top of your head
down to your toes and see if everything
is close and be easy and relaxed and at
ease or you stimulate this just bring
this to ease as much as you can not
everything is in your conscious level as
much as you can consciously
bring it to ease you will see suddenly
if you are the kind who'll fall asleep
at ten o'clock if you simply one hour
you sit here at ease you will see your
sleep will get postponed by half now you
won't feel sleepy at 10:00 naturally
you're awake so instead of trying to
increase the sleep quality
now you increase the quality of life if
you increase the quality of life when I
say increasing the quality of life
nothing in your life whatever you may be
doing from simple breathing to any
complex activity that you do in your
life the quality of that will not
improve if you cannot do it with ease is
that so only when you can do something
with total ease let's say you're riding
a bicycle you should ride in like this
like this you can't say you are enjoying
your cycling if you can write it with
ease with so much ease that even if you
take off your hands it'll go only
straight the way you want it to go
you're at ease because it you are at
ease the quality of your cycling has
improved isn't it
so these two things are connected so if
you enhance the quality of your life
naturally slip quota will go down if
your quality of your life goes bad you
can't do anything with these then also
you cannot sleep but stressfully you
cannot sleep not because you're well
rested you cannot sleep you cannot sleep
because you're stressed out if you do
this you will not live long if you your
body does not get enough rest it will
die it will break something will go if
you are not at ease that means you are
in this ease you're heading there you
are in this is means you're in a certain
state of ill health but if we say your
deceased that means you're dead so don't
move in and stay into the direction of
this ease move into the direction of
ease if you become totally ease sleep
quality sleep quote I will come down
quality of sleep will be good because
quality of life is good now I've got a
special bonus cup that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the best live 30 questions of the
day it's not enough to just watch a
video you have to do something about it
so pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below here we go push number one what
will your winding down routine be number
two how will you prioritize getting
quality sleep in your calendar and
number three how can you improve your
sleep environment and if you're doing
the best live thirty challenge with me
put a hash tag best live thirty in the
comments below we want to celebrate you
so I usually go to sleep around midnight
and I usually wake up around 7:30 set up
in 7:30 somewhere in there that's a
typical day it's throwing around every
now and then but that's that's kind of
typical for me okay so as an
entrepreneur right with like a crazy
schedule because I know you're a such a
schedule like you have your set days on
when you produce episodes when you do
your you know
public appearances right like with you
know blab and just go on other people's
podcast it's like how do you manage all
that how'd you manage to really get
enough sleep with all that crazy
schedule yeah and I have an added thing
where I have a really weak for means
immune system like if I don't sleep
seven hours consistently at least I get
sick if I go two days in a row a bad
sleep I'm sick I guess it's you got a
phone call there bro yeah it's supposed
to be on mute yeah I get sick like I'm
for people who've been watching my
channel there's a lot of videos where
I'm sick and it's often because of like
either lack of sleep or just you know at
the dance studio there's always lots of
people and you know you catch
viruses so I need sleep if I if I don't
get sleep one night the next night has
to be solid or I know I'm gonna be up so
how do you ensure that you get that you
get your seven hours then yeah so a
couple couple things I think some of
them are basics that you probably heard
before you know try to keep to the same
time try not to eat like a heavy meal
before going to sleep because at least
that keeps me up I'm super sensitive to
light so I I have a mask on that that
you know like if I travel I forget my
mask I'm having terrible sleep but some
other things that may be a little
different than what most people are
doing one we have no electronics in the
bedroom so there's no software no
bedroom there's no iPad in the bedroom
there's there's nothing with a light you
know like can people stay up and read
that like blue screen and that just
keeps you awake and so our phones are
plugged in outside the room and so my
wife has an alarm in the morning she is
gonna get up out of bed to go turn it
off this is nothing electronic in the
room so that one house because before
we're kind of sitting in bed next to
each other before we pass out and I
think one it also kind of gives you a
little more connection because there's
there's nothing to read so you talking
to you
but I think you know you get so
distracted by emails and news and stuff
so so no electronics in the room and
that's that's how both of us I think
sleep - is when I get an idea I go and
take care of it so I'll get out of bed
sometimes you go to bed with with an
idea like ah you know I got a great idea
for Julian's dance studio man and then
and then you lie in bed trying to forget
it and in you know wrestling with it and
for me it'll keep me up all night and
and I'm gonna worry that I'm gonna
forget it because I don't have a great
memory if I don't write it down it's
gone and so I will get up and send that
email off to Julian to tell him about
what he needs to do for his day in
studio or whoever it is and then it's
like it's released because otherwise it
stays with me and I have a terrible
sleep and so I'm not afraid to get up
and out to solve whatever is kind of
that that monkey in my head that I need
to release it having a routine to help
you wind down I find super helpful so
just like you know when you're a kid you
have you have a routine that your
parents give you right like you have a
bath and you brush your teeth and you
get a bedtime story and like you get
used to that yeah routine and then that
helps you like Oh your body sets a
shutdown right and then we kind of lose
a lot of that when we get into adulthood
and it's it's I used to find it really
hard like I come back from my salsa
studio after a great night and I'd be
why you're like talking to people I like
I just can't go to sleep right away so I
need to create a schedule a little
routine to to decompress a little bit
and so whatever it is for you it's great
for me we start by I light a candle so
we have a candle since we don't have
electronics in the room we also turn off
the light so light a candle that's on my
wife's side and that's how I start you
know I'll then open up the bed and like
make space for both of us and then go
and like brush my teeth and just read
some news to like decompress and get my
mind off business you know floss wash my
face go to bed do some cuddling and then
go to sleep and so it's like the same
thing every night and then as soon as I
go to the bed
to turn on the candles I start wind out
compressing winding down and then I
start getting tired and after like the
15 20 minutes ticking to do everything
else and I'm ready to go to sleep so
having that kind of routine whatever it
is for you I find helps if you want to
join the best life 30 challenge click
the link right here below me or if you
want more videos on building a powerful
evening routine check out the playlist
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you soon